There is something very interesting going
on.
And my concern is that it will simply lead
to the reelection of Donald Trump in November.
And what I'm talking about is that many self-described
progressives are turning on longtime progressive
heroes, even calling them sellouts in some
cases.
This has already been happening with Bernie
Sanders since last week.
It is now happening with Noam Chomsky.
Noam Chomsky now says that Donald Trump must
be defeated and that Noam Chomsky will vote
for Joe Biden and that this is just ultra
clear to Noam Chomsky and Chomsky, even when
as far as to liken the never Biden people
to the enablers of Nazis from the 1930s, referring
to communists who refuse to ally with Social
Democrats against Nazis in Germany.
This is enraging many leftists.
Let's take a look and then discuss.
This is from an interview with medi- Hassan.
Let's listen very carefully to what Noam Chomsky
says.
What do you make of the Never Biden movement?
It also brings up some memories of the early
thirties in Germany, where the Communist Party,
following the Stalinist line at the time,
took the position that everybody the US is
a social fascist, so there's no difference
between the Social Democrats and the Nazis.
So therefore we're not we're not going to
join with the Social Democrats to stop the
Nazi Party.
We know that there are many other cases like
that, and I think we're seeing a rerun.
So let's take that position.
Never bite Mark on the vote.
But there is such a thing.
There's a thing called arithmetic debate.
A lot of things with motor rhythm.
Failure to vote for Biden in this election
in a swing state amounts to voting for Trump.
It's one vote away from positions.
So if you decide you want to vote through
the destruction issue of yours truly increases
sharp increase in war for your stuff.
Issue here was not lawyers who make it impossible
generation to do it.
And with that one video instantly, many who
have for decades revered Noam Chomsky as the
standard bearer of progressivism and leftism
are now relegated to alleging that Noam Chomsky
has sold out, that Chomsky is a tool of the
DNC because in the end he ends up voting for
Democrats.
And a ton of leftists are throwing Noam Chomsky's
perspective in the trash.
And we're seeing something similar with Bernie
himself, because remember, as soon as Bernie
said last two weeks ago and then last week
first Bernie said, I'm out.
Then Bernie said, I'm endorsing Joe Biden.
Then Bernie said it would be irresponsible
not to vote for Joe Biden.
Just this quickly, those who three weeks ago
were saying Bernie is the most genuine, trustworthy,
honest politician out there are now saying,
I don't trust Bernie.
He's given into the DNC screw Bernie.
I'm never voting for Biden.
Bernie has become a tool of the DNC.
So this is really important stuff and I want
to break it down in pieces.
What we have here are people who have agreed
with Bernie and Chomsky for a long time on
essentially everything, saying Bernie and
Chomsky are wrong on this.
That doesn't mean that they've always been
wrong.
And I actually think that that's fine.
That's totally reasonable.
Nobody agrees with anyone on everything.
I would be falling prey to destructive, logical
fallacies if I were to say, if you supported
Bernie for a long time, you must agree with
Bernie that we have to vote for Joe Biden.
That would be a fallacy for me to say that.
It would be a fallacy for me to say.
If you have for decades revered Noam Chomsky
as the standard bearer of leftist leftism,
you are wrong to now say Chomsky is wrong
about BI.
That would be a logical fallacy.
And so I'm not going to do that.
But there is a difference between sort of
agreeing and disagreeing on individual issues
versus believing that someone has at a fundamental
level sold out because of their approach to
an election.
And what I mean by that is maybe you agree
with Bernie on health care and you disagree
with Bernie about free college.
Great.
That's fantastic.
Let's debate policy.
Nope, no problem whatsoever.
You might agree with Noam Chomsky on imperialism,
but you might disagree with Noam Chomsky about
education.
Great.
These are just simple policy disagreements.
But that's not what's going on now.
And that's what scares me.
Because if you agree with Bernie on issue
A and you disagree with Bernie on issue B,
many of Bernie's followers like him because
they see him as a genuine, principled, trustworthy
and honest elected official, in contrast to
much of what is out there to now say when
Bernie says, hey, we've got it, we've got
to vote Biden to now say Bernie has sold out
and has collapsed under the pressure of the
DNC or whatever.
That's not disagreeing on an issue.
That's essentially saying you've misjudged
the character of Bernie all along.
Are you really that bad, a judge of character,
that you were tricked by Bernie for years
or decades, only to now realize he's sold
out as a DNC shill?
It's kind of weird.
Same thing applies to Chomsky saying Chomsky
has become a DNC tool because he recognizes
the importance of removing Trump.
That's not.
I agree with Chomsky on war, but I disagree
with Chomsky on welfare.
That's saying all along I believe Chomsky
to be something totally different than what
he is on the basis of saying we've got to
remove Trump.
Bernie and Chomsky are being realists.
They're being harm reducers.
They're objectively analyzing the choices.
It's down to Biden or Trump.
And both Bernie and Chomsky, widely trusted
and respected leftist figures, have made a
choice that makes sense to them.
And now people who revered them for decades
are saying these two are untrustworthy.
So either you've been terrible judges of character
about these two all along or maybe they're
still the same people you believe them to
be.
And as such, they're simply correct that the
best move is to defeat Trump by voting by
it.
For me, it's clear.
Let's come together and remove Trump.
I'm ready on Twitter.
Let me know where you disagree I'm Dee Packman
on Twitter.